who are
you oh cool guy back
there so today is going to be a fun day
because it is disy day Disneyland day
and today Nevada's birthday and today is
Nevada's birthday so on Nevada's
birthday or Nevada
day Nevada they turn to a different age
I'm seven now there oh everyone get
everyone turns a year older yeah
everybody turns old so oh okay but yes
on Nevada day there is no school I don't
know what other things happen in the
city or in the state um but there's no
school for taica Nevada day this year
landed on a Friday so today's a Friday
and I was like literally this week I
looked at Bart and I'm like hey so T
doesn't have school on Friday we we're
about to enter November we haven't taken
him to Disney
was it has it been this whole year maybe
this whole year and I'm a SoCal baby um
I grew up on Disney I love Disney this
guy is kind of whatever about it we did
lose out on Disney for maybe two and a
half years what is going on I like
smelling what he's smelling he always
smells as bushes so to smell as bu yeah
that's his favorite
blanket um so yeah Disney was closed for
like 2 and a half years because of the
whole pandemic so taica lost out on a
lot of time that he could be falling in
love with Disney so he doesn't like it
that much we don't really watch Disney
movies at home cuz he care less about it
he's too busy watching Jackie Chan and
Bruce Lee and all those type of movies
Killer movies by the way but yeah maybe
I'm doing it more for myself where I'm
like I miss Disney and I need my son to
miss Disney so I'm like I looked at bar
it was maybe like a Tuesday night and
I'm like we should take that to Disney
cuz it's a Friday um as far as I know
only only people in Nevada don't have
school so it's the perfect time to go
it's not going to be super packed who
knows I don't know what to expect um so
we'll see but I'm super stoked to be
going back to Disney I got the park
copper so I'll be going between two
parks cuz there's Disneyland and then
there's California Adventure which in my
opinion now seems like California
Adventure is like the like it's
awesome
so um yeah I'm so stoked today's going
to be a fun vlog T are you
excited can't you tell can't you tell he
can't contain himself I have to like
tell him to be quiet every 5 minutes
hopefully this Tri trip makes him fall
in love with it cuz every other trip
prior to this he could care really less
so if today he doesn't fall in love then
it's confirmed I'm the only one that's
obsessed cuz this guy never went growing
up he could care less about it I love
Disneyland you love it yeah I love it
love love love love um super love not as
much as you but I love it it's very fun
place it's very magical reminds me of
all the the childhood movies that I
watched maybe three times cuz my mom
didn't let me yep I don't because they
have Cheerios have Cheerios churos oh
well then you like Costco then so I
guess we're all going for the right
reasons but all very different reasons
so let's get this PARTA started the
coochi waha the coochie
waha wink wink wink why I can't see your
wink cuz you're wearing glasses cool guy
there it is there it
is this was always my favorite
sign when coming to
Disneyland
yay and then like you think the magic
starts here but no I like wait but
where's Disneyland I can't see
it there's a scientist Disneyland Resort
and another Disneyland sign that's where
we're going and a Disney way there it is
way yay yay
yay I love Disney way you
do okay I like I like those YY cinnamon
things all the TRS okay the guys kids
everyone's going to Disneyland I know
hey there's a Spider-Man on Dad's Papa
on the Papa's back and the dad's Papa's
Cy this is my first time coming on this
side I'm not even sure where we are but
paying for parking
and it just I see no trace of Disneyland
anywhere
so this will be fun never came this way
before but I don't feel the magic just
yet do you feel the magic no because I'm
confused where we're at but I do feel
the pain of my wallet cuz parking is 35
or 55 for
preferred it already hurts I'm excited
yeah yeah you're paying free dude you're
paying
nothing I'm my okay so happy accident we
ended up parking at um it was off of
Harbor Toy Story parking lot and it
takes you directly to the park we skip
all of that no tram it was just a
shuttle straight to the park do that
heck but we are here now and ta has no
idea ta we're here
dude look at that big old booty was it
hard okay no more no more we're going to
enter the park dude okay this is this is
California Adventure side okay now I
know where I'm at we go that way ooh
look at that look at the pumpkins so
later hey later we'll go to California
Adventure hey later we'll go on this
side right now we're going to go to the
Disneyland side over there pumpkin where
the pumpkins are
woohoo oh my God the decorations are so
damn cute look at
that
we are officially inside the park and
this is always the craziest so I tried I
honestly tried to avoid this side but
isn't it the most iconic picture cuz
everyone knows where you're at it is but
it's like that and I don't really care
for it I feel like busy today the look
no there's a line usually it's slam slam
it's all the way out here like that like
it's like Time Square no I don't need it
I've had it and it's it's okay does he
have it
she I'm okay okay fine let's go I don't
think he cares for it either find your
[Applause]
Rebel monkey what do you think
dude there yeah okay we do have to take
a picture by the big pumpkin that is a
must yeah yeah yeah yeah we got to do
that if there's a line we might have to
wait
though look at this we're on Main
Street what do you think monks whatever
he's like it just look like a city to
me oh
[Music]
man look look at the bubbles are
happening we yes for the
[Music]
trolley yeah Mama what's the trolley uh
the thing that the horse was pulling oh
no no no that's not it um oh it's not
here
yet look at the
pumpkin so we goofed and we thought we
can get breakfast out here we can
however you need res
now
everything so we found this little C
spot I don't even know what it's called
but it's right at the entrance right on
Main Street we just walk in and pick up
your food so Papa got a croissant T got
a cant an a croissant yep just like that
good look that a breakfast mhm what's in
there cheese EG the good stuff and I got
a
parfait he's like Computing all of it
all right taica our first is Adventure
Land that's we're going look at
this huh yeah those are tiki torches
real
fire you can go in there there's a show
where birds sing to you I think his pyro
jeans are just like his Papas when you
burn down the chiro pack yeah okay so I
think the first stop is going to be
Indiana Jones okay dude I have to make
sure that you're tall enough for the
ride so I think it's one of these or we
can do the jungle cruise no I got to do
Indiana Jones first okay let's go to
Indiana Jones you saw that I'm I'm
already yeah so did you can you get on
the Indiana Jones ride you measured
yourself and you can do it we passed the
test everybody he's tall enough for the
ride there red lines you remember those
red lines yeah and like and I was tall
all the red Lin
yeah you can't go on there hey does not
Berry Farm look like this what does not
Berry Farm look like there's a guy a
cage oh okay he didn't he didn't realize
what my question was
but
oh I don't think he's at the level we
can understand the difference of
branding just yet yeah yeah I think
everything's cool oh look at the jungle
Cru behind you Ross monkey
I'm okay I don't know what just happened
but a really nice worker here I guess
maybe recognize this and she goes hey
follow me and she put us in the fast
line so now we're on the fast
line monkey you go go we're in a cave wa
to the other in here watch the
movie look at Monkey we're going to find
a
[Music]
treasure
oo it's so dark in
here I'm following you
dude I'll follow you go go go just
follow the path you can't get lost I
[Music]
promise are you scared Dude any not
anymore to see people oh you see people
good job wait a minute what's Happening
Here What's Happening
Here what why is it so blurry
[Music]
now no no no we're
good all right
monkey it's our
turn let's go monkey man
[Applause]
woohoo here we go monkey
man no
watch it's so dark I can't record you it
is your
Desy all right monkey man you just
finished Indiana Jones how did you like
it really good but the ball and and the
the little job was kind of scary that's
it that's all was scary that was only
that was scary yeah everything else fun
mhm yeah there's no other scary part no
that's it what like this like going like
going super fast like this no was I was
fun wow all right okay next
ride next ride jungle
cruise let's go big
booties
cool huh look at
that tell
[Applause]
me come come
on keep far into the heart of the Jungle
I do need to remind everybody to stay
seated hands arms feet legs all body
parts inside the boat and do watch the
little ones sweet as they are I'm not
going to that has sailed for me I'm
done with all that you know what I'm
saying over here on the right is our
very first sign of danger how about that
we're not off the dock a minute and V
right into the face of danger beyond the
danger sign we have Indiana Jones in the
temple of the Forbidden eye where some
of the most dangerous jungle animals
live looks like some of them have made
it onto this boat as well you know the
little ones they latch onto the big ones
for 18 to 25 years there guarding that
sleeping zebra
a I know I know the zebra looks dead
tired to me too but that is how zebras
sleep in the jungle Eyes Wide Open necks
bent tongues out legs stiff those lions
are having their favorite snacks next
ride
is Pirates of the
Caribbean are you ready to look at some
Pirates my little pirate booty Mak
pirate well I can't hear you if you
don't talk in my direction T again
pirate booty oh the popcorn yeah
yeah well you know what booty means
it's like a treasure or your butt or
your butt yeah true or it could be your
treasure butt your treasure butt pirate
booty
booty pirate booty booty pirate booty
yep there we
go are you ready to look at some Pirates
young boy
PIR kiss
you okay another dark one sorry y'all
cutting it here TAA how did you like
that ride really good where are we what
are we doing
now we're getting
[Music]
Charles yes we are getting tros check it
out
yum
[Applause]
there it
is choros have been acquired not the
best yeah why what does yours
have Papa House chocolate at toffee say
chocolate and toffee chocolate and
toffee and look you have zero I have
zero mine's the OG the OG Original
Gangster how much was it 40 bucks
each
forgot I can that one oh thank you house
how nice of you good job now we're
leaving Adventure Land and heading to
tomorrow
land you ready for the future monkey man
that one no a different one we're going
to do the I like the Buzz Lightyear one
it's a game we
play
yep the
fine all right you Junior space
listen up
[Applause]
Z Our
Miss Rob there's Buzz
Light so it's going to be Tao versus
Papa I'll be the oh we're stretching
[Music]
who okay let's
go
[Music]
[Applause]
ready and remember Target
are that's good game do you know what to
do and this spins it okay anytime you
see a little circle you have to start
shooting at it that's those Circle oh
wait where is it at you get all the
points with the oh with the Z with the Z
you see the Z's look right there you
have to hit those
targets got
[Applause]
it up there up there look up there up
there up
there your space producer spin will Joys
spin control is now activ you may begin
little red
light to deter your rank whoa look at
how many ta got Pap got
Che you
win sure you got all those points mama
so now we're in the
car T's going to take a
nap because if you haven't been
following his health um he or the lack
of sleep triggers his seizure so we want
to make sure we have as much control
over the things we can control one of
them being the fact that we could
control one when he takes a nap so we
just left the park we're still in the
parking lot but we brought all his
sleeping
stuff he's going to take it out and
we'll go back easy
peasy and the little monster is away my
little
manman yeah like an hour and a half I
thought she said 2 hours just about 2
hours closer to 2 hours just about 2
hours in a little comfy bed back there
looks so comfy I wish I could sleep back
there nice and horizontal got his little
avocado pillow and we got blankets the
sheets and everything look his eyes look
so well
rested it's Cy yeah and Papa's Got the
AC blasting some classical music I
didn't want to describe it too much uh
before cuz he was winding down and going
to sleep but now we're ready to rock and
roll we're going to go to California
Adventure now w w w w
w let's
go Nice Part yeah yeah what's what's
up so uh just W up first place we're
going now is California
Adventure California
Adventure so I'm super excited there we
go so welcome to California Adventure no
you got to follow me dude this way no
more no more racing okay have to follow
look at the trolley
dude yeah all right so the first thing I
think we're going to do we're going to
go to the grizzly something I forgot
what it was called we're going to go
check that out Grizzly Rapids maybe I
don't know uh before it gets too cold
then we don't get like super freezing so
let's go monkey
man look at that a short it's short
let's do Pluto I take a picture of Pluto
yeah okay let's do it
go how beautiful does all of this look
look this is where we're going to come
down look at that look all that yeah
we're going to go down that thing you
want to do
it that one let's see what it looks like
come here come here come here come here
excuse us
look is anyone coming
down not yet look I want to see if they
come down here I want to see what it
look
like ready 1 two three they're not
coming down is it even
open okay what are you saying monkey man
how high would it be super high like
that high yep but I'm so scared a little
bit Yeah I said the
jellyfish oh well we'll do that one
after I said I wanted to do the jelly
fish before this right okay we're going
to get on this one are you okay
yeah straight up he a
little so me so it's you here we
go oh
boy oh boy did it go
fast not too
fast no open your eyes you should
look is this hot
me oh we're flying he look at that's
what we look like on that
side
who are you
scared is this
H yeah a little bit oh yeah so I oped it
out of the jellyfish one just so that I
can film these
[Applause]
cuties getting in trouble
already he totally told us to do that
and Papa was not listening
[Applause]
look how you have a sea
[Music]
[Applause]
on W they're so
high oh that's so it's so gentle I think
Papa's going to be okay guys I think
Pap's going to be
okay papa is such a stud he found the
cream cheese filled pretzels in a matter
of
seconds they are right
[Applause]
here okay so they recognize this and
they hook this up with free pretzels
it's really warm and I'm so
grateful did you get the cream cheese
there cream cheese in the middle and
it's so good good look at
[Applause]
that I love all the marachi that's
playing they were just playing peso
pluma
too hell yeah my peoples I'm more of a v
Fernandez guy a who V Fernandez hey not
bad you've been with the Mexican long
enough to know that he's jez you
know what I'm saying yeah I don't know
about these new
guys
go
[Applause]
[Music]
you okay
dude you have a good time
dude put your arms up go put him
up oh my
[Applause]
God oh my God
are you okay are you okay that was a
crazy one your face was funny are you
okay A little one coming a little one
coming okay so that was surprisingly a
lot of fun I didn't realize how fun that
was going to be taica that drop what
happened I turned and I looked at you
and your eyes were so big did you get
they like this big yeah did you get
scared what happened were the drop
scary that's that's do you want to get
on it
again oh okay come on let's go dude we
lost say cheese cheese one
more cheese M oh
yeah look at how cool this looks it's
beautiful
[Applause]
huh
so
red like that in the gas station right
this yeah that's it flows okay so I
wanted to try going to the web Slinger
Spider-Man ride and I was so stoked CU
I'm like I didn't even know this existed
I'm so excited to try to check it out
and I wanted to share it with you but as
we're waiting there and it's almost like
it's bedtime well like we're kind of
timing it all out but like actually our
weight time increased to an hour we're
like okay we got to go so we're leaving
and we're still in Avengers is it called
Avengers
land it looks so cool I can't wait to
come back and see this in the daytime
cuz I don't know what it looks like in
the daytime we have Guardians of the
Galaxy back
there oh my God there's so many people
now but yeah we're heading out we're
making our way out the park I think this
is our last
stop P true P true P ta's
request true
he's been really good all day today he
gets all kinds of snacka
Woos look at how cool this is it's right
in the
entrance look at that when you're inside
California Adventure so we are back at
my mom's house and man what a great day
we got on so many rides and we met so
many of you guys and honestly I'm blown
away at your generosity like you guys
saw it throughout this Vlog um we were
getting free food we were getting bumped
in line and like it always blows me away
at how kind you guys are and we never
ever ever ever ever expect it and
honestly we never feel like we deserve
it at all for any reason so anytime you
guys offer this kind gesture we're
always going to be like no no no it's
okay it's okay it's okay um but when we
do receive it we're always like oh my
God we're like so blown away and we're
so so grateful and it's so unexpected
and it's it's so sincerely appreciated
and again we're always like we don't
deserve this stuff like you guys are too
kind you know like I don't know you guys
are rad and um yeah we're just blown
away we're just blown away by how kind
you guys are to us whenever you know we
ever do meet in person so thank you for
always being so so warm and so kind and
just come in and say what's up it's it's
really nice to meet you guys um
but for today lesson learn park at Toy
Story and I didn't really need the genie
plus I didn't buy a genie plus and I
didn't feel like I needed it other than
ju or just for haunted mension
cars and that was it well me I guess
Spider-Man but that one cuz it had like
a technical thing like throughout the
day it kept like temporarily closed and
then it would open and then again
temporarily closed so I think they were
just having some technical issues um but
yeah man get on the app place your
reservations we ended up sleeping in the
car so if you go with little kids go
leave the park go in the car turn the
engine on turn the AC on everyone takes
a freaking nap everyone felt better
after the nap I napped Bart napped ta
obviously napped and we were so charged
up refreshed that we were like able to
keep going with no grumpiness no crying
no nothing it was great um overall such
a wonderful positive experience the
weather was great the crowds was almost
non-existent until night time it did get
packed it felt like people were like
yeah the weekend so more and more people
started coming but it was fine cuz we
were just already leaving um but what a
success I can't remember the last time I
went to Disneyland and I got on more
than like three or four rides like this
was an absolute
killer success and I love Disney
so much oh my God I
hate I hate that we don't have Disney in
Vegas Vegas get a Disneyland
night but I know it's not going to be
the same but man it was
awesome sorry if was all shaky and
stuff I think I was just like really
really like letting my inner child take
it take it all in so I'm like so this
Vlog was probably trash I'm sorry but I
had such a good time and I think I had
an even better time because I got to
share it with my little son and got to
see Disneyland Through The Eyes of a
six-year-old and it was so rad cuz
there's so many things that like I take
for gred now as like a 40-year-old
um that when I see him experience it I'm
like oh yeah I remember feeling that so
it was awesome reliving all of Disney
through him anyway on that note I'm
going to take a shower change rest up
callor a day thank you so much and again
always always always always always so
damn
grateful for all the love that you guys
give me and my family like we'd be
without you guys so thank you again love
yall good night